[MUSIC]
People issues are fundamental
to competitive and addiction.
That's exactly what this
program is all about,
the intersection of talent management,
culture, and performance.
People is a vehicle for
you to become not just bigger but
better, by being more innovative,
more efficient.
And then thinking of how can your
people management processes help you
shape culture so
that you can achieve performance?
>> This program can shift
your entire mindset
about the way that you
lead in the people space.
And help you transition from
a traditional HR model and
people's strategy to
something very cutting edge.
>> We'll present research,
on not just start-ups, but
much more importantly, scale-ups in
Silicon Valley, and in particular,
their talent models and
what is it we can learn from them.
>> Learning from the Silicon Valley
best practices is obviously not
a bad place to start if you're
looking to recruit good talent.
>> To be here, in Silicon Valley,
learn from all kinds of innovative,
talented people is incredibly inspiring.
And I think you walk away with
some really concrete tools and
frameworks that you can apply
in your organization right away.
>> This program really is meant for
people who are keen to question their
own playbook for talent management.
Think of it as a gym where you
can actually build new muscles,
work on new parts of your organization, so
that when you go back, you actually have
an agenda of things that you want to
subtract from your organizations and
also add to your organizations.
Tools that you can begin to
use when you go back to work.
>> The mix of theory and practice gives me
the best ideas and tips to take home with.
[MUSIC]
>> The ideal participants are HR
leaders from large established
companies seeking to redesign
their talent playbook.
And business executives heading product
groups, strategic business units,
And even corporations who can
actually initiate change.
>> The blend of international people, the
one that attend here alongside world class
speakers that sets this course
quite apart from the rest.
>> The diversity of the class,
being able to engage in dialogue about
people strategy with individuals who
come here from all over the world.
And have different roles and perspectives,
it's really, really fascinating.
>> It's a set of frameworks,
it's a set of social science-based tools.
It's a set of corporate experiences,
that actually provision you
to develop your own agenda.
>> For anybody considering
taking this course, do it.
It's a life changing experience.
Something you'll never forget.
[MUSIC]